No what's that smell of lemon I'm not
sure smell of lemon
I mean why nurse would you need air
freshener in here is such beautiful woof
yeah this is smell in here is crazy now
just quickly up the window
I guess the back your throat right yeah
somebody to make up the best they are
made I've seen dog baskets better hold
away they put in about five years ago
bloody hell seriously yeah there's
definitely old blood I don't think so
sure it's a stain anyway Wow
okay so I'll be down couple minutes or a
bite to eat sounds great yeah would you
recommend she does the rainbow trout
here what's her name her name is Jeannie
okay great thanks the update thanks AK
wow the view is breathtaking but the
color is depressing I mean honestly
everything's dark and gray and dingy and
the pillows look at those how uninviting
but the dog sat on it for the last ten
years really do smell what is that it's
like a piece of candy stuck on the
pillow it's terrible it's almost like
they're falling out of love for this
place the melody of love to hear people
shagging in the next door no you must
hear something Wow
holy mackerel is that mold in there I
wouldn't be surprised if it were mold I
with the Wardrobe secondhand why check
out wardrobe right over there I'm
feeling really nervous right now I know
that the room was really cluttered but I
didn't realize it was
well at least we have a light bulb
there's a man that goes round nicking
light bulbs out of the lamps Mandy said
that he doesn't then turned on some guy
called Jim he's your father
yeah mum works in the business as well
kind of goes around and helps clean up
after people's mess are they owners as
well Restless so your parents bought you
this place when we saw this place I knew
I had to have it so I found every single
way possible to convince my daddy no
matter what I had to do I just had to
have it
I personally think they could have
gotten it for cheaper they probably
should have okay
I can't believe you're gonna be in room
16 why cuz room 16 has a ghost in it
this woman told me who went to room 16
she said the ghost was pulling the
blankets wrap her all night long and you
haven't been drinking sherry Wow many
years ago set the Curtis house and
people do tell us that she raises a
little bit of havoc with them she's
definitely there room 16
the haunted room my goodness me where's
the helmet footprint No so was a little
big stuff yes it looks like a footprint
to me almost like dead bugs oh dear Oh
cheeseburgers well here I give you a
list of the rooms that are coming in
they're supposed to throw a check the
room
that was week two we have electricity
Nelson I couldn't believe what Gordon
found in that room and what's this
nobody just realized our care Wow
beautiful room and I mean this is a this
is a beautiful but seriously it it does
smell different [ __ ]
I mean that is horrific oh my god it
smells like sewage
we had a plumbing issue and slice it
shut under the bed and how much this
room goes for three hundred and fifty
dollars a night three hundred and fifty
dollars a night for room the smells of
[ __ ]
well you're kidding me we haven't rented
it though Valachi how it's been out of
use for four months four months yeah oh
come on it has been this is crazy
it is crazy it's just like spent I've
got to get out of here stinks [ __ ] it's
another room yes I have room - bloody
hell I didn't realise $350 Wow yes it's
so empty more like a go in the guest
room and how much is this a nice seven
fifty nine seven hundred and fifty nine
dollars wow that's incredibly expensive
what's that thing there that is actually
the jacuzzi tub in the middle of the
lounge
it is in the lounge Wow because I'm the
rooms they took away all the interior
walls but without sounding stupid these
are car designers correct they are car
design now they've put in jacuzzis in
the middle of suite last time I checked
a living room was for sitting if not
taking a bath
how much these things cost the jacuzzi
tub itself is about twenty thousand
knives if you don't take baths ah this
is crazy
who wanted all these specially design
that is their own areas that's Eddie yes
this is crazy
oh [ __ ] a sports car inspired furniture
looks cheap and isn't even functional
it's different than anything else
different from a nice hotel room I don't
know about that hoo nothin want to sit
here and sort of watch the television
and watch the television it works so the
sheets how can also wrinkle well have
you except in there why is that we do
them in house we say we would you mean
you don't do laundry lifestyle means
everything your mouthwash it's like gas
sock is all broken and smashed down
there and someone's left that dirty ones
there the plastic plants that's
outrageous $100 oh my gosh Gordon
doesn't like anything about the hotel
damn it
anything else if I have any lifestyle
needs I'll call thank you of course